yo sup guys its Marcus Brownlee here
from mkbhd and we've got another
hardware video coming your way this one
being the Matthias unboxing check out
that title and that's what we're
basically getting into here today this
is going to be a your unboxing video of
a review video again with most hardware
it comes within one to two weeks after
I've gotten you know the chance to use
it for a while so let's basically just
get it get into the package right here
this did take a very long time to ship I
notice and you know the keyboard was it
was in the mail with IUP USPS high
priority mail and it did take a couple
couple weeks actually to ship out to a
pioppi so you know we'll get into it
we'll see ya the exactly what is in the
box you know what comes in the box if
there's anything special that I should
let you guys know about and that's
basically it so here we go um so I think
I need this anymore let me just get
these things out your way in paper
shipping info just a little note there
and at the USB 2.0 keyboard so got that
set that box off the desk sorry guys so
basically what this keyboard features is
a USB 2.0 hub in the back as well as
this being the keyboard with the world's
first USB 2.0 dock if that's what you
want to call it as advertised on their
website which I have pulled up next to
me right here as I'm uploading in a
review video so let's actually just go
ahead and see what we get in the Box
here there's a little bit of paper
something maybe I'll just pull it out
the side so the obviously this does
connect to your computer via USB it
looks like it's going to have a little
height adapter going on so let's just
see if we can get into the clock
have some info some specs actually about
the people around back there we go we
actually do a little sneak peek that's
the dock on the front of a keyboard so
here we go this is the only keyboard
according to the box with a USB 2.0 dock
as well as a hub in the back so I see
here here we go open this right up and
here we have the keyboard itself facing
the opposite direction I'm just gonna
spin it around here it's got some
plastic wrap on it and we have our
instructions and that looks like if
they're Spanish or that we got a quick
step guide basically staying it up you
have obviously a USB 2.0 keyboard to
plug it in to your computer so this is
basically the quick step guide if you
want to check that out on the basically
nothing's really special about the box
we're going to get into the actual
keyboard so I'm just going to take the
plastic wrap off flip make sure you can
see it it's looking pretty clean nice
clean design we'll see you know the
travel of the keys and everything in the
review video basically I see two USB 2.0
ports on this end meaning one for the
dock and one for the one for the
keyboard itself here's the orbital USB
2.0 dock so if you've never seen it just
go ahead and get a USB stick over here
USB 2.0 4 gig it's good and plug it
right there cuz easy is that so if you
ever want to eat you know you have a
ipod you gotta plug in the cable real
quick sync up your music before you head
out the door that's going to be optimal
for you
so if you do like if you have a lot of
USB cable I know why do you guys are USB
fans you can use a lot of USB devices
we're going to see about how how fast
this hub on the back of it goes there is
the to point you to port USB hub let's
look on the back of it here real quick
where you have a few adjustable height
stands there we go so we will be able to
adjust the height get a little off the
ground have a more comfortable typing
angle so we'll definitely use that and
you
go into this keyboard well I basically
see you know how we like typing on how
fast it is how it sounds I see already
some little LED lights for the num lock
caps lock etc so yeah we'll get into
them too this keyboard more I'll use it
definitely as much as I can I see a
little extra symbols there we'll see
some volume keys it's very cool mute
button right there yeah it looks very
very clean so uh yeah I'll get it get
back to you guys with the full review of
this mattias keyboard of ESCO i say it
and i'd you want to check it out the
link is in the description so go ahead
and check out that link right there guys
yeah thanks for watching I will
definitely get back to a review video in
one to two weeks and until then stay
tuned peace